in the area of confidence we have a lot
of trouble properly interpreting the
level of confidence that other people
express one thing we do is we attach too
much significance to how confident
someone seems and appears and acts in
other sense we prefer confident people
more than less confident people even
when they're actually less accurate and
and less knowledgeable so for example
I'm a Dutch psychologist named Gideon
Karen did a very clever experiment where
he said simply two people here are two
other forecasters and they've given the
forecast percentage chance of rain on
four consecutive days forecaster a says
there's a 90% chance of rain on Monday
and 90% chance on Tuesday a 90% chance
on Wednesday and a 90% chance on
Thursday forecaster B says there's a 75%
chance on Monday 75 on Tuesday 75 and
Wednesday and 75 on Thursday in fact
after those four days it turns out to
have rained on three out of those four
days that is 75 percent of the days
which weather forecaster do you think
was the better forecaster now the right
answer is forecaster b-because
forecaster B said there's a 75 percent
chance of rain
and he was right on 75 percent of those
days it actually did rain he's what we
call perfectly calibrated but a majority
of subjects in this study preferred
forecaster a and the only difference
between forecaster a and B as a
forecaster a is more confident
forecaster a is sort of more decisive in
his forecasts but less accurate
yet we still prefer that forecaster even
knowing their track record and here we
actually know what their track record is
so we should really be able to say look
this guy got it right he's the right one
but instead even knowing their track
record we go for the one who's more
confident and this is an unusual case
actually because you've been given all
the information you know it and you need
to know to make the right decision if
you think about people who forecast the
stock market or who forecast political
elections or a forecast you know trends
in shopping and design and so on we
don't know what the track record of
those people are when we pick which ones
we like better so we're even more
seduced by confidence and we don't
realize that we're paying so much
attention that we think we're making a
better decision than we really are
my research is in sort of two areas one
is traditional cognitive psychology and
the other is cognitive neuroscience a
more modern field that uses technologies
like brain scanning to figure out how
what's going on in the brain explains
how our minds work and these are
exciting developments and exciting
technologies that enable us to learn
those kinds of things and I'm all for
them but we do point out in our book
sort of one unfortunate side-effect of
some of this new development and we call
the side effects neuro babble and brain
porn and neuro babble is sort of the
adornment of explanations about the mind
with references to the brain a lot of
people think that if you can say
something about the brain then you must
know more about how the mind works and
it really doesn't work that way the
brain the mind are not entirely the same
thing just seeing a picture of the brain
with some colorful blobs showing this is
where the brain is active while we're
doing some particular tasks doesn't
necessarily tell us a whole lot more
about that task and how our minds
accomplish it
likewise a lot of talk about the brain
is often used to sort of as an add-on to
other arguments to make them seem more
convincing it's sort of like an
all-purpose you know reference to make
your argument more convincing is to say
it has something to do with the brain
and show a picture of the brain and so
on advertising does this quite a bit as
well you can see the brain if you look
in all kinds of advertisements where
when you think about it it's really not
that relevant and I sort of am a little
bit troubled by that trend while at the
same time I think it's exciting to
discover more about the brain it's just
as long as we know what that knowledge
means and that it doesn't mean that
traditional psychology is somehow
obsolete and replaced by neuroscience
and so on they're two topics of study
that definitely relate to each other
quite a bit but the one doesn't replace
or really make the other any more
credible